let's get to our caller from the three
one three area code caller from three
one three what's going on who's this hey
is that me that is you hey David um this
is Dante calling from Southfield
Michigan how are you
good what's going on not much just a
quick question so I'm pretty much uh I
pretty much think of myself as a nobody
but what else if I wanted to run for
some kind of office where would I start
depends what's available where you live
I mean it might be if you depending on
where you live City Council might be
accessible just by getting five hundred
people to vote for you you can knock on
that number of doors and make that
happen it might be running for a
committee within a city it could be you
know depending on where you live
could be state rap I mean that's really
very location dependent Dodge okay okay
I guess I would have to look for into
that because I'm not trying to look it
up but everybody seems kind of scarce
but if they're pretty easy to figure out
though who your elected officials are
and all of the different positions that
that exists where where you live in
Michigan that should that should be
findable information okay yeah I'll have
to definitely look into that because I
want to try to I want to try to start
getting more it
what did following college just on I've
never tried to run for office because
it's like yeah not really I'm not really
known or anything so um but I appreciate
that
alright would be your big issue like if
you ran for elected office what would be
your primary issue that you would focus
on so one of my primary issues um if I
read for a local office it would
definitely be to uh it would definitely
be increased the amount of recreational
um the amount of recreational facilities
for children and even a dog okay that's
interesting here's one bit of advice in
local elections traffic related stuff
can really really work because that
affects so many people everyday if you
can make the case that you're going to
improve the traffic situation for people
that can be a way for a so-called nobody
politically to start making some headway
just think about it think about it ah
that is a good idea
okay I'll definitely look into that so
though it was just a short question but
I appreciate been watching your show I
started watching so like last Jared I
appreciate it thanks a lot ok good
thanks for calling and appreciate
hearing from you